[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens ils sont un peu
chers je trouve c'est tout le reste ça
va
ouais bah y'en a beaucoup ces fréquences
et il y en a partout il faudra qu'ils
soient là toute la nuit aussi je serai
bien ou du moins certaines lignes oui ça
se trouve c'est ans est mis en place
je voterai blanc bonsoir à tous frangin
gourhant de piqueteurs permet à tout le
monde ce pour hâter canada apprend ça
les joueurs que je connais je pense
toutes les stations de métro
l'essentiel par les nouvelles mais
pratiquement tout est votre elle en
pense quoi
mon frère licoco sabich je ne rajoute
pas je n'arrivais pas bible ni début ce
n'est des métro supplémentaires parce
qu'il faut que l'heure de pointe on est
les actions des autres et votre sol en
pense quoi
je suis fille unique les voies prendre
sa voiture ou des transports voilà tout
seul et votre elle en pense quoi
mon frère où il prend toujours des
transports en commence toujours ces
moments forts ainsi je pense au maillage
du métro sur sa géniale passe composite
et danser n'importe où sans avoir besoin
de ce nom de sa voiture et battraient
ils en pensent quoi
pareil sur le conte le prendre de temps
en temps et que c'est russell demande
il ya un manque d'organisation total et
surtout c'est en proclamant papa et
c'est très cher pour ce que c'est votre
est il en pense quoi
mon frère mon frère ah ouais alors vous
et qui tente de francs maçons de merde